all right folks Tina's going to tell you
more we had a little bit of weight and
balance before that fight planning the
sample but Tina is now going to give you
the the real story so you guys all ready
to go out and get your drones license
good I'm really glad all right we in
balance so we talked a little bit we've
actually had quite a few discussions
throughout about stability about where
the center of G is how that affects your
controllability of the aircraft so
weight and balances and not only an
important thing to know but it's a
required thing that you have to do
before you go flying each time and one
thing that's also relevant is to
understand the center of gravity and you
want to make sure that center of gravity
is within the limits for your given
aircraft so we talked about yesterday
when we were talking about aerodynamic
flight that certain aircraft have to be
reinforced to do certain operations so
again it really has to do with that and
and by the way from yesterday mark left
behind some of his aerodynamic procedure
diagrams if you want to take a look at
that those are up front well one thing
that really you have to keep in mind in
terms of what the aircraft can handle is
just what is the max gross weight so
what are what can this airframe sustain
in terms of stresses on its body we also
talked this morning about performance
and discuss you know certain things like
the distance the length of the runway
and the distance you need to take off
are affected by how the airplane is
weighted so we're going to talk about
those things specifically and then one
thing I have on here is if you go over
your gross weight then you get into test
pilot territory and right after this
after we'll grab lunch and come back
we'll hear from Joe Joe a test pilot
he's going to tell you some really cool
things as well all right so it's just
some basic terms to get started off so
when you're thinking about an aircraft
one piece of information is its standard
empty weight so that's the weight of the
airplane and there's also some fuel in
the tank that sometimes it's hard to to
drain and when you when you refill that
fuel kind of sits at the bottom and
can't be used by the aircraft so that's
the unusable fuel and then there's some
different fluids and fuel oil inside the
aircraft so all those count in the
calculation of the standard empty weight
there's also the basic empty weight
where you have some optional equipment
inside and we'll go to a aircraft's Poh
to look into what it actually reports
about what it contains there's also a
good rule of thumb to know about what
weight you're going to associate with
the per gallon of fuel so it's generally
good number is six pounds for the fuel
that you'll be using it's slightly more
for different types of fuel so right at
the beginning of the class we talked
about weight which was the force pulling
the aircraft down which has to oppose
the lift pulling it up so the weight
actually you know becomes less as you
burn fuel so when you take off you have
all the fuel on the airport craft as
you've been flying for a while that fuel
is used and the aircraft has less weight
so there's a fully loaded aircraft has
something called the maximum ramp weight
so that has fuel that will be expended
even when it's just taxiing over to the
runway and so you make certain
assumptions about how much fuel you'll
actually burn off just taxiing up to the
runway and then before you take off and
so when you're calculating the weight of
the airplane when it takes off it'll be
slightly different than how you fueled
it when it was sitting parking on the
ramp okay some of the biggest things
that you would keep in mind that you
change every time you get into the
airplane so there's the weight of the
passengers the baggage you take with you
and then how much fuel you fill the
plane with before you take off so the
a load in this case is the passengers
and the cargo so whatever baggage and
the weight of those bags that you take
with you so one thing to keep in mind in
addition to just the weight we have to
figure out where that vector that force
vector acts on the aircraft if all of
the weight is really at the front you
might have a center of gravity at the
front which will create a moment on the
airplane so it'll cause it to bend in a
particular direction and if all that
weight was acting at the back of the
plane you had a lot of really heavy
bricks at your tail which is not a good
idea it would cause that force vector to
act over here and create a moment so
that's all related to torque which we
talked about before so it's also
important not just to calculate what the
weight is of the airplane wants
everybody and everything is inside but
also where how that weight is
distributed in the airplane and how it
affects the airplane the center of
gravity all right so I think that many
of you have already it looks like most
most folks in the rooms were either MIT
undergrad or grad student which means
you already understand some of these
basic physics terms about torque and
moment so we'll just cover them very
briefly the moment is the weight times
the arm so basically where the weight is
times how far away it is from a
particular location that you're
calculating it from so we're gonna do a
couple basic examples so we have a
seesaw here so in this case whenever
you're calculating your moment you have
to pick a reference point and make sure
you're consistent as you use it so in
this case they have a their data point
is at that triangle at that fulcrum in
the middle and so they have a moment on
the right and a moment on the left so
you see various rectangles that
represent different objects or different
weight and then they calculate it so
that blue box that's five pounds is ten
inches away so to figure out what the
moment is that it applies you just
calculate the weight times how far away
it is
okay so in order to figure out what the
center of gravity is you might want to
consider where you're doing that
reference point so rather than doing the
reference point from right in the middle
of the aircraft in this case they're
starting at the end so where that yellow
line is where it says datum is where
they're starting and then they're there
using the lengths from that same
reference point so now you have a purple
box of five pounds that's ten inches
from that datum and then three pounds
and a green weight that's farther and
the red box that's the farthest away so
here they've listed all those different
boxes and the the weight of each of
those boxes times how far it is you
multiply that to get the moment that it
applies and use that to calculate the
location of the center of gravity and
just in terms of if you've if you've
been on a seesaw before who has been on
a seesaw before all right good I'm glad
so as you know that that fulcrum or
where that triangle is if you put that
triangle at the center of gravity so all
the the kids sitting on one side of the
seesaw weigh the same as the kids
sitting on the other side of the seesaw
at the appropriate lens away so they're
applying the same moment than the the
fulcrum balances so if we determined
what the center of gravity of this
airplane was and I put my finger there
then it would balance and it wouldn't
tilt one way or the other that's the
whole idea so for for a given aircraft
there is not only the center of gravity
but in the testing process they could
they understand what is that approved
range of where that center of gravity
can be such that the aircraft is still
stable
so if it if you're thinking about
putting a lot of weight at the front of
the aircraft then and less weight at the
back of the aircraft that in the center
of gravity moves forward and there's a
limit to how far forward that center of
gravity can be that allows the plane
still to be stable so that's the forward
CG limit and then you see the same thing
at the back aft just means back so how
far back the center of gravity can be
all right so we've already discussed
some of the performance things but just
to just to remind you you know what are
some of the things that can happen if
your airplane is is overloaded you want
to just shout out some things that you
would experience if you have a very very
heavy airplane yes very good just to
repeat it longer to takeoff so we have
takeoff and landing distances increase
so if you have a very heavy airplane you
may not be able to take off from a short
field runway and then of course it's
talking about if your aircraft gets
outside the approved envelope it'll talk
about what we mean by envelope then it
then it hasn't been tested to be stable
at those areas and so now you've become
a test pilot which you may not want to
do again we're gonna hear from a test
pilot very soon okay so what happens if
not just that it's overloaded maybe it's
still within the envelope for the total
amount of weight but what if the center
of gravity has moved too far forward and
passed that forward CG limit so your
plane naturally wants to be nose-down so
what is the impact of that well it'll be
harder to climb right it's harder to
climb because your nose keeps that keeps
pulling it down for example what does it
mean to have a stall speed increased is
that a good thing
and why not why is it not a good thing
yes basically if your stall speed has
increased that means you're likely to
stall at a higher speed so if you you
know traditionally can can fly at 60
knots without stalling but that stall
speed has increased from say 40 knots up
to 60 knots and that means that when you
traditionally have been able to fly
safely at 60 knots you could actually
stall at 60 knots so an increased stall
speed is bad what about an aft CG having
the the weight too far to the back what
is the impact there you tend to pitch up
right and so one thing that they are
talking about here is Flair so this is
when you're you're coming into land
you kind of go down but then you sort of
flare up and it could actually over over
flare and that can cause some really
strange things when you're trying to
land such as bouncing and you definitely
don't want to do that but all these
things you might actually just notice
when you're feeling the airplane it acts
differently than you want it want it to
act so here's just a basically a
cross-section if you took off the the
wings and the top of the fuselage and
you're looking at the plane it shows you
know the pilot sitting in the left seat
a passenger and the right seat two
passengers in the back this one actually
has a third row of passengers and then
two baggage compartments so this is just
showing you know traditionally when
you're loading up an airplane that
payload again is your passengers in your
baggage where do they sit so now I'm
going to go over to this document viewer
and talk about specific airplane the
plane I like to fly a Cessna 172 okay so
this this book is talking about a
particular aircraft as Skyhawk so it's a
Cessna 172 this is a plane that many of
you guys might use as a flying aircraft
we've also talked about for example a
piper we just
lowing airplane that you might use so
this is what a Cessna looks like it has
that tricycle gear at the bottom
whatever plane you are using for
training I would get very familiar with
this book and in particular remember
what the table of contents is because
when you get your oral exam on your fa
examination it's ok if you don't
remember everything what's really great
is if you know how to find information
and you can say hey you know if I didn't
remember this I would go look at my poh
and I would go look at the weight and
balance section section 6 of my book and
I'd be able to flip and find this
information very quickly so oftentimes
you'll get questions in that oral exam
where they would ask how you would go
about finding information we discussed
that a lot with regard to weather data
what are the sources of weather data so
with regard to weight and balance the
information about your airplane as found
with a book made about your particular
airplane and if you're at a particular
flight school and we'll show you that in
an example they might have they most
likely have all of this weight and
balance information listed in a
spreadsheet sometimes it's accessible
online so you know for your exact
airplane what its gross weight is so if
we flip to that section 6 it has a fair
amount of information including the
picture we just showed you so it talks
about in this case there are only two
rows of seats so the pilot and passenger
one row of seats so it seats four people
and then it has a baggage area but
what's really important to understand is
that even though this Cessna can fit
four people will show you that if you
put you know four 200-pound people in
there with a bunch of bags you'll
actually exceed the allotment so just
because there for seeds doesn't mean you
can take four large people on a flight
some of it is is something we'll keep in
mind and maybe you can reduce bags and
reduce fuel such that you can make that
weight work out so we talked about
envelopes
so the envelope is basically a a line on
this graph that shows where the center
of gravity can be and the envelope is
where is it safe to be so if you're
inside the envelope so inside this line
if your calculations result in the
center of gravity inside then you're
within the envelope if you're outside of
it then you're not you can you can see a
little pencil mark towards the top where
I took a flight recently and I was
trying to calculate whether or not I was
inside and in fact I was and it's okay
that I'm right at the edge of the
envelope as long as you're inside you're
still with inside the tested limits now
there are two different categories are
two different lines here there's a
bigger line that says normal category
and then there's a smaller line that
smaller envelope that's talking about
utility category does anyone know what
the difference is between normal and
utility G limits is that what you're
going to say so there's different
restrictions one question you might get
asked is how do you find out where the
answer is
and it's right in here right where you
would think it is and I'm actually going
to show you a real example so we're
going to go through an example of you
know loading up an airplane don't want
to embarrass anyone but we might ask
some of you what your weight is so
beware so every time you have to
calculate your weight and balance you
can do it by hand or you can use a
computer to do it and I would just
caution that you have to double check
all the information so here's a great
link that tells you for a particular
Cessna 172 a weight and balance
calculator so here you can actually type
in the empty weight now there's a big
warning here use your own AC data what
is that saying what are the AC aircraft
use your own aircrafts data so look at
your actual information from your school
to figure out for the plane that you're
renting what that what those pieces of
information are so here is a link from
East Coast Aero Club just as an example
and they have provided for every
aircraft that they have a bunch of
information so for each aircraft they
have provided the empty weight and the
CG the moment gross weight useful load
and then they also talk about two
different settings for fuel so there's
you can have full fuel or fuel to tabs
so that is something you'll hear pretty
frequently you know fill the fuel two
tabs so if you want to have extra mass
extra extra weight in your plane you
have some heavier folks flying with you
you might only want the fuel two tabs
but if it's just you or you and your
instructor and you want to fly a
cross-country flight you might want the
fuel full so these are all things you
can change this calculator has some
restrictions which is that the kind of
the weight is is identified here in
terms of
so they have the the oils you might want
to check what is in the oil level inside
your engine for a Cessna 172 six quarts
is a really good number to have but you
check it every time during our
pre-flight it could be five quarts it
could be seven quarts
so you want to double-check that and of
course if you see that it's low four
quarts you really want to ask someone to
fill that up before you go flying but
the other thing here is you actually
list the the weight of the people that
are sitting in the front and the back so
I talked about embarrassing folks but
let's not let's not embarrass folks
right now so let's say the pilot and
let's say you're doing some great
resource management you have another
pilot sitting next to you is your
copilot is there and you also have some
some big folks sitting in the back both
the left and the right side and you know
you want to take a bunch of pictures and
stuff but you you want to get as low as
you want so you put in some bags so this
it's actually hard to see because
there's too much weight this this red
little plus sign is showing where your
center of gravity fell and whether it's
within that utility or normal category
so in this case we have three people
front two or 200 pounds each one person
in the rear with 200 and bags they're
weighing about ten pounds does this is
this safe to fly no so your little red
dot went outside the limits and you have
a much smaller person sitting in the
back seat you cross over that line and
now you're back into the normal category
so you can fly again another thing you
can alter is of course the fuel fill the
fuel to tabs so this is also talking
about so most of the time in the in the
Poh book so the section six is about
weight and balance so although the one
example I just showed you was for a
Cessna 172 the piper warrior also has
that
sistent so really recommend just
memorizing the table of contents for
your Poh so the way that you go about
calculating it is the same way we
entered it into their little calculators
so first you have to determine the basic
empty weight of the aircraft and then
the moment section six almost always
also has a place for you to do that
calculation and so they have a place
right there where you can you know enter
in your airplane the moment and it does
the same steps that we just saw on the
slide so you start with that basic empty
weight then you focus on the fuel and it
gives you the six pounds per gallon as
what you're going to most likely be
using what is the max number of gallons
what is you know the amount four tabs
you want to actually look this up for
your airplane the weight of the pilot
and the front passenger the rear
passengers and the baggage area and then
you get this ramp weight and as I talked
about you can actually have your plane
be a little heavier than the envelope
right when it's fueled on the ramp
because there's some allowance for the
fuel that your burn off during taxi and
so that's right here so fuel allowance
for engines start taxi and run up so
they took off about eight pounds over
there and then you can calculate it and
once you locate the point then you go to
that diagram right here so you you go to
the weight and the moment and you figure
out whether you're not whether or not
you're in the safe whether you're not
you're in the envelope for that normal
category of aircraft so what we just
went through is the same procedure
that's listed right here and so here is
it just doing that same example for a
particular Piper warrior so they have
the basic empty weight of the aircraft
just as a hint if it's something round
like 1500 then you probably didn't get
the exact accurate amount so again if
you look at the the real thing there
you're getting it down to some very
specific accurate numbers
so like 1190 6.63 that means you got a
real number here's our piper warrior and
so they have the basic empty weight the
passengers in the front and the rear
they don't have any bags here right now
and they they basically multiplied the
weight times the arm the arm is really
indicated in the in the book and in
these calculators as to where where the
location is of the chair now of course
the seats slide forward and back but
usually they don't they don't get into
that many specifics and then you can
calculate here the moment so next we do
the ramp condition so ramp condition is
basically what's the weight and loading
of your airplane once it's fueled up and
sitting on the ramp then you in this
case they took off seven pounds for that
taxi and run-up and then your takeoff
condition in this case it's two thousand
four hundred and forty pounds and it has
a moment here as calculated so you
basically do the same thing we just
showed so you look at the the weight on
the left and they'll CG location as the
vertical line and you see where those
two lines intersect and you see whether
or not it's inside the envelope you can
also check the landing condition in
general you will have burned fuel during
your flight and so your landing
condition will be lower but you know you
might have heard big big jets and you've
heard that sometimes they have to do a
fuel dump why do they have to do a fuel
dump well maybe they calculated their
landing based on having flown across the
country but their flight across the
country was canceled because if weather
or whatever and so they had to dump
their fuel in order to land which you
don't like to here is once they've
dumped their fuel then you have another
delay in the air and you're like hey
what happened I thought we dumped all of
our fuel but of course as a small little
airplane dumping fuel is not really a
procedure you're gonna be doing so it
might be a good idea to just calculate
the landing and the runway lengths with
the full fuel in case you know you have
to
landing right then and there before
you've flown all the distance you
thought you're going to get to fly so
yeah in general as you can see that
where we were beforehand was higher and
the weight goes down so your landing
condition is almost always going to stay
within the envelope there's some some
places where if you're CG is too far aft
or too far forward where actually that
reduction in weight could cause you to
come outside the envelope alright so
there also a lot of spreadsheets
available you can make your own
spreadsheet pretty quickly in Excel
using the data from the particular
aircraft that you're renting or buying
alright and these are just some of
snapshots from the the book that we just
looked at and they show pictures of
where the seats are in the airplane in
order for you to calculate that you
could also calculate the moment left to
right it's pretty easy to think about
though that in that tiny little airplane
if if you're sitting on the front and
the left and no one's sitting on your
right and you have someone sitting in
the back on the left you're gonna be
tilted over it's very easy to fix that
problem just make sure you have someone
sitting on the other side I have noticed
some of these effects before I'm a
little bit of a smaller person and there
was a very very large instructor sitting
next to me and actually could tell as I
was flying that it was a little bit
tilted and so the the future flights we
put some more bags on my side and it was
a little bit more evened out usually you
won't run into that too much as an issue
in some of the the small like puddle
jumper aircraft is so a commercial
aircraft they have sometimes a situation
where there's only one row of seats on
one side and then there's the aisle and
then two seats on the other side have
you guys seen that configuration I'm
getting a lot of head nods so in that
situation they might enforce that you
have to sit in the seat that was
assigned to you and when people try to
move you know from the the side that
only had one seat in the row to the side
that has two seats because they just
want more space to spread out they
might say hey for weight and balance
reasons you have to sit in the seat that
was assigned for takeoff and so that's
what they're talking about there any
questions about weight and balance
do you guys think you could do weight
and balance calculations yes okay I'm
getting a lot of head nods so everyone
took physics that's good good job yes
hello laughter question I will actually
defer to Philip who flies helicopters
quite frequently so once he's back we'll
ask him about helicopter cge limits good
question
anything else
so the question is do when you're
actually flying do you do this
calculation every single time or do you
mostly only do it when you're really
loading the aircraft so it's actually
required that you have the weight and
balance done the reason you don't do it
every single time though is you
frequently fly in the same configuration
so if you rent from a flight school you
might frequently rent you know a couple
aircraft and you might frequently you
know fly just yourself doing a solo
flight or fly with your instructor so
you might just keep it stored that you
have you know a couple pieces of paper
in your flight bag that are the weight
and balance calculations for what you
almost always fly and is almost always
within the normal category envelope but
you definitely want to do those
calculations if you're getting you know
passengers in the back seat whenever we
go on these MIT fly outs we actually ask
people for their weights and and it's
actually a big restriction too so when
we're trying to get passengers to sit
down just because I fly a Cessna with
four seats as we just saw from the
example I don't have four pass and you
know I don't have three passengers to
offer I often say you know I have 220
pounds available and so they then have
to sort out Sebastian and his team as to
who to assign to my plane versus another
plane and also if people aren't being if
you if you notice people aren't being
overly forthcoming about their weight
you might want to increase the amount
that they gave you yeah I mean let me
let me add that I obviously have a lot
more experience being over overweight
then Tina might have but also yeah
actually these pants are a good example
twenty years ago some friends and I we
made a web front end to a Levi Strauss
Factory that could make custom cut
khakis so we asked people in the web
form when they ordered
what's your waist size what's your
inseam what's your height and weight and
from that we had software to try to
infer their actual weight their actual
waist size and then we make them you
can't really see this but these pants
just say pair number seven they don't
say anything about what size it actually
is they would get their pants this was
in 1990
and they would get their pants if they
didn't fit they'd say look it needs to
be a little looser in the waist it needs
to be a little shorter and then a
revised pair would be made and sent to
them but we never relied on their stated
weight or their stated waist size
exactly so there is a question for you
that I wasn't able to answer about
helicopter CGS and really thinking about
was it the lateral CG what was your
question
it's very hard to get to the question is
yeah it's very hard to get a helicopter
out of lab as with an aircraft if you
have you know two heavy people in the
back and a light person in the front
it's easy to get out of the front back
CG longitudinal CGG but he's talking
about what we just discussed you know
it's frequently the case that you might
have a forward CG or a nav CG but you
but you don't usually have an issue with
the CG on the left or the right
unless I mean it's very visible and a
four-seat aircraft it how to fix those
types of problems one issue with the
Robinson is they put the main fuel tank
on the left so they're budgeting for in
a solo situation a pilot of at least a
certain minimum weight in the front
right so very lightweight like sometimes
when teenagers are learning to fly
helicopters they have to add a little
bit of ballast let's say like a big
heavy you know Jim weight like a 50
pound Jim like Jim wait in the front
left foot well or something the other
the other thing that could go wrong is
so when you do your pre-flight one of
the things that you do is that if you're
sitting and the pilot seat so on the
left side so - you're right in the
middle at the bottom there's a little
knob where you can say whether you want
the fuel to be coming from the left tank
the right tank or the or both and pretty
much all the time the checklist says
that after you've parked the plane you
want to twist it to the left or the
right and the reason is you don't want
while it's sitting there fuel to be
sloshing across a plane and so you you
set it to left for example now if you
skip that step
even though it comes up several times
throughout your your pre-flight and then
your
run up check if you if you didn't put
the fuel to draw from both tanks and
it's only drawing from one tank then you
might experience that that instability
all right why don't we should we take a
15-minute break so people can run out
grab food bring it back and then we'll
hear from dojo about the test-fire bill
and life potentially outside of the
limits
you